un français en tenue de soldats dans un
hôpital d'Ukraine Maxime bronchin
originaire de masse est parti combattre
aux côtés des Ukrainiens
j'ai entendu l'appel de du président
zélinski au début de la guerre où
j'avais été militaire par le passé
j'avais été pompier je ne sais pas
combien et du coup je pensais me rendre
utile
il part donc en mai finançant lui-même
son gilet par balle et son casque sur
ces images qu'il nous a fourni on le
voit en action sur le front-est mais le
27 novembre à nouveau ses villesk il
marche sur une mine et se blesse
grièvement pied gauche
[Musique]
mais qui lui a sauté deux fois sur une
mine et qui est décédé pendant son
évacuation
Maxime bronchin sera d'abord transporté
dans un hôpital de querquy falaise puis
ici à l'hôpital militaire de Kiev il a
subi 6 opérations
parce que ces gens ont vraiment besoin
d'aide
je me fasse amputer ou qu'ils arrivent à
sauver mon pied après ma convalescence
je pense revenir
le ministère des Affaires étrangères
assure lui apporter l'assistance
nécessaire et indique qu'il serait
évacué vers la France